الجيش الاسرائيلي باطلاق ثلاث قذائف
صاروخيه من سوريا نحو اسرائيل حيث سقطت
قذيفه في منطقه مفتوحه جنوب هضبه الجولان
واوضح المتحدث باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي في
ادرعي بانه تم تفعيل الانذار في مناطق
مفتوحه بالقرب من بلده في منطقه جنوب هضبه
الجولان مشيرا الى انهم يعملون على كشف
مزيد من التفاصيل حول ذلك
نتابع اخر التطورات من القدس مع زميل زياد
حلبي زياد ما الجديد بشان اطلاق ثلاث
قضايا صاروخيه من سوريا باتجاه اسرائيل
حاليا يحاولون ان يعرفوا من اطلق الصواريخ
طبعا
الترجيحات ان تكون اما جهه فلسطينيه او
انها هو تابع لحزب الله او شيء من هذا
القبيل لكن في المحصله عمليا سقط الصاروخ
فعليا في الجولان المحتل الجنوب الجولان
المحتل قرب احدى المستوطنات لم تطلق
سفارات كما خالد الجيش الاسرائيلي وانما
فقط عبر التطبيق لان الصاروخ سقط في منطقه
مفتوحه
عمليا هناك يعني حركه نشيطه للقاتلات
الاسرائيليه لا نستبعد ابدا في خلال ساعات
قليل لان تقصف اسرائيل المنطقه التي خرجت
منها الصواريخ الثلاثه
وهذا قد يتم فعلا لاحقا لكن علينا ان نشير
ايضا الى ان هذه الجبهه لديها ميزه تختلف
عن الجبهات الاخرى وهي طبعا الرابعه الان
بعد القدس والضفه وغزه وجنوب لبنان
وبالتالي هذه الميزه هذه الجبهه بانها
عمليا لا تقود الى تصعيد كبير بهذا المعنى
اسرائيل تقصف بشكل دائم في سوريا والليله
قد يسجل كهذا
وهي تبقى جبهه مريحه لردود الفعل
المتبادله عمليا بمعنى حزب الله واسرائيل
لم
يخططها الدخول في حرب بسبب اطلاق الصواريخ
الاخير من جنوبي لبنان
تجنبا ذلك حاليا هذه الجغرافيا تتيح الرد
وتبادل الضربات بدون ان يقود ذلك الى الى
مواجهه شامله طيب زياد هل سجلت الجبهه
سوريا اطلاق صواريخ من هذا النوع مؤخرا
لن تخوني الذاكره قبل ثلاث سنوات فقط كان
هناك رشقه صاروخيه وهي اعقبت ايضا اطلاق
صواريخ من لبنان وكما توتر في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه وصولا الى حرب على قطاع غزه
هذه الاجواء بدات تشبه تلك الاجواء الى حد
بعيد طبعا عشرات القذائف سقطت في الجولان
المحتل من سوريا ولكن
يعني في سياق اخر كانت قذائف عن طريق
الخطا عندما كانت
هناك قوه متصارعه في جنوب سوريا بين
النظام والفصائل المعارضه مدير مكتب
العربيه في القدس زياد حلبي شكرا جزيلا لك
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات